Elizabeth Smart says she believes one of
her kidnappers being released from
prison is still a danger the now 30 year
old young woman was abducted more than
16 years ago by Bryan David Mitchell and
Wanda bars II she was 14 years old at
the time they held her captive for nine
terrifying months before they were
captured and convicted bars he was
released from prison this morning after
serving her 15 year sentence and only on
CBS this morning we went to Utah a
couple of days ago and spoke to
Elizabeth Smart she lives there now she
says she knew this day would come but
she doubts at bars II regrets her role
in the kidnapping all those years ago
you said she has shown no remorse to you
at all part of her plea deal back when
her case came up it was required for her
to write an apology to me but it was
just a very brief I'm sorry for what
I've done the end kind of thing and you
felt nothing from that no I don't think
you can just kidnap a fourteen-year-old
girl and not only sit by her while she's
being raped but encouraged the rapist to
continue and then just at the end of it
say I'm sorry and really mean it you're
a woman and a mother too to think that a
woman and she's a mother of six can
encourage a man her husband to rape you
I can't even wrap my brain around what
that was like or what that did to you
well first of all I don't think she
deserves the title of mother she may
have birthed six children but she
certainly was no mother
you said that you're not a vindictive
person and that you have forgiven her I
don't feel that I could have moved
forward in my life had I still been
holding on to hate and anger inside me
because that would still be taking up a
percentage of my soul and that means
that you know I wouldn't be able to love
my own children 100% I love my husband
100% because a part of me would still be
taken up with anger you always had a
pinprick of Hope where did that come
from if you're raped on your very first
night and every day after that by two
clearly deranged people how do you still
have a pinprick of hope I had to turn
back to my family and that's really what
sustained me was knowing that no matter
what happened to me no matter what
anybody else thought no matter if I ever
had another friend in my entire life my
family would still love me and for me
that was worth it you said something
interesting you said you know had this
not happened to me I might I might have
naively thought that on some level it's
the victims fault it's true I might
naively have thought well what was she
wearing what was she doing why didn't
she run that was silly of her why didn't
I mean this is terrible thing that's
happened but why didn't she do more and
now that I've been there I will never be
that person ask those stupid questions
because what you're really saying is you
should have done more Elizabeth you were
in your house though we were in your
house you should have been the safest
place for you but it shouldn't make a
difference you know shouldn't happen if
I was an innocent 14 year old girl or a
girl working the corner your children
are very young how old are your children
and what if anything have you told them
about your life
my daughter is 3 and my son is 1 what
will you tell them when the time comes
well we have conversations right now I
mean I want my daughter to know first
and foremost that I love her no matter
what I love her unconditionally because
that was ultimately what served me
in surviving my kidnapping was knowing
that my parents loved me unconditionally
prior to being kidnapped I was
definitely that girl who loved happily
ever after and I'm getting married and
having a family and relieved in
fairytales yes when I was kidnapped I
remember just feeling like it had all
been ripped away from me and so once I
was rescued I just remember feeling like
I am NOT going to let life pass me by
yeah I marvel at Elizabeth Smart you
know I asked her have you ever had
therapy how have you gotten through this
that you were not in the fetal position
just totally screwed up and she said you
know what really got me through she said
is her family and her music playing the
harp she said she had some therapy she
said yes but from time to time and I
said are there triggers that sort of
trigger you and you have flashbacks or
breakdown she said the only time this
happens is when I want to talk about it
so I don't live in a constant fear that
something's gonna trigger me or
something's going to happen and the main
thing she wanted to say know is that you
you must blame the perpetrator not the
victim KLCC though many people miss that
part I just think she is so wise yes to
listen to her and her saying whether it
happened to a fourteen-year-old girl
home or a woman working the street she
does not deserve that and let everybody
sink let that sink in I had like a
moment when let that sink in yeah cuz I
actually thought you know why didn't you
run why didn't you she said you know
that's just that's not even a fair
question he's the power of telling these
kind of stories it's such an acute
experience for her but it tells us all
something about the power of love and
loving unconditionally even if you don't
have this kind of challenge there are
all the other kinds of challenges where
unconditional love and a family is the
thing you hold on to that's what's so
great about the Jews I agree with you on
that
she's as we said yesterday she's happily
married and waiting for baby number
three so I cuz of a smart cheer me want
always bless